aujourd'hui 18 octobre bonsoir nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités la parole à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité vous
en avez l'habitude depuis le début de
saison de ce nouveau rendez vous et vous
entendrez ce soir notamment jean-luc
ghislain responsable de la croix rouge à
saint quentin en yvelines
il lance un espace bébés par an à
guyancourt une structure d'écouté
d'appui et d'accompagnement nous
parlerons également de toutes les
activités qui sont proposées par lacroix
rj et puis arnaud courtier le directeur
général de la fédération française de
cyclisme nous présentera les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste qui débute demain à saint quentin
en yvelines au vélodrome nationale la
croix rouge de saint quentin s'apprête
donc à lancer un nouveau service à un
espace bébés par an sur la commune de
guyancourt une initiative est née d'un
constat la famille et le premier lieu de
construction de l'enfant et de
transmission des valeurs et des repères
d'où cette attention toute particulière
dont nous allons parler avec jean-luc il
un bon soir mon responsable président de
l'unité locale croix rouge
à quoi va servir concrètement cet espace
bébés parents qui va ouvrir dans
quelques jours maintenant à guyancourt
mais bon comme comme vous l'avez dit un
peu
en démarrage c'est une structure
d'écouté d'accueil pour les jeunes
mamans ou jeunes parents je pense que
tous les gens qui sont passés par là
savent que
après la naissance il ya en général un
petit petite période de stress était
période de dépression et tout ça pendant
lesquelles on a besoin de pouvoir
éventuellement partager ses doutes de
parler de deux de ses petits problèmes
poser quelques questions auxquelles on a
pareillement n'a pas toujours été
préparé donc l'idée c'est d'offrir donc
assez jeune maman et jeune papa la
possibilité de venir s'exprimer par les
poser des questions et avoir des
réponses donc l'armée assure un
accompagnement plutôt psychologique est
ce qu'un accompagnement matériel aussi
qu'il sera proposé
alors les familles en difficulté voilà
pour les familles en difficulté qui nous
seront envoyées par les ccas ou par le
conseil départemental où les différentes
associations des alentours
nous avons prévu de pouvoir parce que
c'est aussi partie de l'activité
croix-rouge de de leur donner un soutien
matériel sous forme de couches de petits
pots de l'air
deux layettes
on a déjà récupéré tout un tas de
matériel de puériculture les poussettes
des sièges autour des
des chaises hautes donc tout ça va être
mis à la disposition des familles en
difficulté qui viendront cet espace mais
mes parents mais ça n'est que l'effet
secondaire je veux dire que l'effet
primaire ce que nous savons nous tenons
absolument s'exposer à l'infraction
principale soit le lien la création du
lien on a prévu d'apporter quelque chose
aux parents fonction de des demandes qui
vont être présentés
on a des pédopsychiatres qui qui
viendront éventuellement si on rencontre
des certain temps ont des difficultés
d'enfants hyperactifs ou d'enfants qui
dorment pas très juste insister sur un
mot vous avez employé à plusieurs
reprises c'est le mot lien justement
l'importance du lien ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des familles qui
sont véritablement isolés qui ont ce
besoin aussi ce qui s'est exprimé on
vous en a fait part c'est ça qui vous a
motivé à créer tout ça ou c'est le
constat que vous avez fait on parlait
tout à l'heure des autres actions menées
par exemple en des maraudes aussi les
interventions sociales que vous pouvez
faire de voir que cette famille était
aussi isolé qui avaient des besoins de
d'échanger de discuter conseillère
assuré oui c'est certain mais enfin je
veux dire que déjà la croix-rouge à une
trentaine de ces espaces qui existent un
peu partout en france dans différents
départements ici dans les yvelines y en
avait un qui était installé depuis un an
et demi aux mureaux donc on sait que ça
répond à un besoin
une certaine importance pour un public
c'est pas forcément un public auquel on
s'adresse dans nos épiceries sociales ou
dans la maraude vous voulez voilà même
vous voulez un autre public va toucher
également c'est pas seulement le public
en difficulté financière que l'on veut
avoir ce sont toutes les toutes les
mamans qui se trouve isolé
et qui ont besoin d'un petit support
psychologique léger on se prétend pas
être des tous des psychiatres des
psychologues mais bon on a beaucoup de
nos bénévoles qui sont des grands mères
qui sont habitués gérer des cancers et
qui pourront donner des conseils à
l'oise et qui pourront accompagner et
puis dans les changes entre les mamans
elles mêmes ou les parents parce que je
veux pas faire de sexisme et c'est aux
parents que ça s'adresse donc papa ou
maman dans les changes entre les
différentes maman est différent par an
il peut y avoir aussi des des conseils
qui peuvent se donner des liens qui
peuvent se créer qui peuvent permettre
d'éviter de se retrouver seul sur les
renseignements pratiques la première
ouverture ce sera le 25 octobre 25
octobre prochain à 9h30 mardi prochain
et les ouvertures ce sera chaque fois
mardi et jeudi c'est à guyancourt on a
par préciser l'adresse par la drees
cette terre place jacques brel donc
c'est à côté de la maison vladimir cosma
c'est dans le quartier des garennes
c'est ainsi facilement joignable par les
bus de ça s'adresse à toutes les
familles de 50 ans décédera chaque
client soit content livre il m'a
absolument se sevrer sur toutes les
familles de saint quentin en yvelines et
pour l'instant on a prévu deux
ouvertures de matinée et puis en
fonction des besoins
on ajoutera à d'autres de mes journées
en fonction de ce que les parents vont
demander autour d'eux des premiers
contacts qu'on va avoir avec eux la
croix rouge se sera donc cet espace
bébés à partir de la fin du mois
d'octobre du côté de guyancourt c'est
aussi ces épiceries sociales
vestiboutique l'équipe de volontaires
aussi qui sillonnent les rues à bord du
véhicule de la croix rouge sont les
fameuses maraude qu'on est mort il ya
maintenant plus à l'heure vous faites
aussi des formations aux premiers
secours
comment vous arrivez à assurer toutes
ces missions bain grâce au dévouement
des sens quelque 150 bénévoles que nous
avons la croix rouge
qui y passent beaucoup de certains
vraiment beaucoup de temps parfois comme
le président que je suis un plein-temps
bon parce que nous on se rend compte
qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup de 2
on peut apporter un certain nombre de
solutions beaucoup de petits problèmes
ou de gros problèmes que les gens
peuvent avoir sous une forme ou sous une
autre escale plus en plus de demandes et
de besoin aujourd'hui qui s'exprime
on parle souvent de la paupérisation dit
régulièrement mais est ce que justement
tout ça ça répond à des besoins
aujourd'hui
oui il ya une certaine augmentation de
la demande mais d'un autre côté il ya
aussi deux le nombre d'adp qui augmente
un peu partout donc quelque part ça se
concrétise à ça c'est bien de tous les
côtés pour conclure est ce que vous avez
des besoins spécifiques en ce moment que
ce soit pour les bénévoles pour les deux
ans on parlait de l'espace parents bébé
ou même pour plus tard pour les
interventions des maraudes pour l'espace
mais mes parents oui on va avoir besoin
d'un peu plus de bénévoles
on sait qu'on va certainement avoir
quelques familles de réfugiés dont les
mamans n'ont pas le temps d'apprendre la
langue et on voudrait mettre en place
des des petits cours d'apprentissage de
la langue pendant que le lait les bébés
sont pris en main par les bénévoles ça
permet de passer quelques heures à faire
de la conversation
une manière concentrée d'être plus
efficace que si on doit avoir le bébé
sur les bras
donc tout ce qui peut nous être apportée
entend donc bénévoles ou en produits
layette
poussettes et autres sera cueilli sa
serait bienvenu.merci absolument le
bienvenu tout est ainsi beaucoup jean
louis vient d'être venu on redonne cette
adresse puisque les équipes en régie
sont très rapides elle va même
s'afficher à l'antenne c'est formidable
tout fonctionne
merci jean luc ghislain cette adresse
située à guyancourt pour le nouvel
espace bébés parents qui ouvrira à la
fin du mois d'octobre merci encore à
vous merci beaucoup pensiones parlons de
sport à présent tout autre sujet nous
partons pour le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
championnats d'europe qui débutent ce
mercredi demain les meilleures nations
du continent européen comme l'angleterre
l'allemagne ou encore l'italie seront
représentés arnaud courtier le directeur
général de la fédération française de
cyclisme est interviewé par michael et
demi d'euros les championnats d'europe
de cyclisme sur piste sont organisées au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du 19 au 23 octobre pour nous parler de
la compétition je suis avec arnaud
courtiers le directeur général de la
fédération française de cyclisme par le
courtier
est ce que ça sera une grande fête
vraiment ces championnats d'europe
bonjour oui ce sera une grande fête
comme à chaque fois que nous organisons
un événement international au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
parce que nous avons des athlètes qui
sont là de nombreux pays pour ces
championnats d'europe
un public local est aussi international
qui vient donc une grande fête une
grande fête du cyclisme
avant tout il y aura des cyclistes de
haut niveau on peut le dire
ah oui des cichlidés au niveau d'autres
au niveau qu'ils soient français qui
viennent du royaume uni d'allemagne
d'espagne de deux pays plus lointains
l'europe sportive et est bien plus
élargie que l'europe politique nous
avons pratiquement une trentaine de pays
qui participent à ces championnats
d'europe et la france envoie quand même
une équipe compétitive avec des têtes
d'affiché des têtes d'affiché laurie
berton sylvain chavanel quentin lafargue
des plus jeunes aussi on prépare la
relève pour l'avenir donc ça va être
très très intéressant à observer
particulièrement pour les années à venir
on est vraiment une opération reconquête
vraiment pour cette équipe de france qui
n'a pas brillé aux jeux olympiques
seulement fait une médaille de bronze
sur piste on est vraiment l'opération
reconquête un ici et on veut le faire
devant un public saint quentinois en
fait exactement on a besoin du soutien
des saint quentinois reconquête on oui
surtout préparation de l'avenir une
olympiade se termine nous sommes d'ores
et déjà dans la préparation de la
prochaine c'est-à-dire tokyo en 2020 et
donc il ya tout un travail qui va se
faire pendant ces quatre années qui
démarre pendant ces championnats
d'europe
on est à quelques jours des épreuves est
ce que tout est prêt le courtier pour
accueillir
une grande manifestation de ce type
alors tout est presque prêt on le voit
peut-être un peu derrière nous tout est
un montage en préparation mais oui tout
est prêt et tout sera prêt le jour j à
l'heure h pour l'ouverture des
championnats
il y aura également une cérémonie
d'ouverture est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus oui une cérémonie
d'ouverture alors je vous donne juste
quelques détails mais on je peux vous
dire seront des enfants des enfants du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
qui vont défiler sur la piste et qui
représenteront les nations présentes
est ce qu'il reste encore des places
donc cet événement oui oui il reste des
places
on ne sera pas sur l'affluence
extraordinaire des championnats du monde
il lui était difficile de faire aussi
bien mais il reste encore des places
donc j'invite surtout les saint
quentinois à venir à l'accueil du
vélodrome nationale puisqu'ils
bénéficient de tarifs réduits en tant
qu'habitant 2,50 en yvelines de toutes
les communes de saint quentin
ils viennent à l'accueil du vélodrome
avec un justificatif de domicile pour
bénéficier du tarif réduit et ils
pourront avoir des places il ya eu les
championnats du monde quand est
organisée en 2015 maintenant les
championnats d'europe
est ce que c'est le vélodrome finalement
monte en puissance au fur et à mesure
des années plus que monte en puissance
et le vélodrome s'installe tout
simplement on a prouvé avec les
championnats du monde que nous avions
une arène internationale
un vélodrome une piste vraiment très
très apprécié des sportifs
donc nous avons le souhait de continuer
peut-être pas avec un événement
international tous les ans mais de
continuer régulièrement et aussi de
montrer que nous sommes prêts
particulièrement pour paris 2024 et
c'est important vraiment pour la
fédération française d'organiser ce type
d'événement les championnats d'europe
les championnats du monde c'est
important pour faire grandir la
fédération encore plus c'est oui
absolument c'est très important à la
fois pour nos athlètes bien sûr c'est
important pour l'image de la france
je le répète quand on est en candidature
pour accueillir les jeux olympiques
c'est très important
donc ça fait partie d'un mécanisme
global mais oui il est important que
nous accueillons régulièrement des
grands événements sportifs
internationaux et le public répond
présent quand même à chaque fois vous le
disais ça se remplit doucement mais ça
se remplit quand même pour ces
championnats d'europe
oui ça se remplit absolument le public
répond présent le public répond toujours
présent en france pour le cyclisme c'est
ce qui est merveilleux c'est qu'on a un
public connaisseur un public parfois qui
vient découvrir parce qu'il ne connaît
pas forcément aussi bien là puisque la
haute mais la piste est un spectacle
fantastique il faut venir dans le
vélodrome pour se rendre compte donc je
un site vraiment les les gens
particulièrement qui habitent dans la
zone à venir mais ceux qui viennent de
plus loin aussi on a des clubs qui
viennent de province des spectateurs
étrangers aussi qui viennent de très
loin pour cet événement dernière chose
est-ce qu'en trente secondes vous pouvez
nous donner envie de venir voir ces
championnats d'europe ici à saint
quentin en yvelines
je vais vous raconter une anecdote en 30
secondes lors des championnats du monde
moi j'étais pas un expert de la piste et
dès le premier jour de la première
médaille j'étais debout sur un fauteuil
les bras en l'air en train d'hurler ça
vous prend aux tripes c'est un spectacle
fantastique où qu'on soit si dans le
vélodrome on voit très bien spectacle
donc même en prenant une place catégorie
3 la moins chère on est très bien
installés c'est un spectacle fantastique
ça n'arrête pas un des sessions démarre
dans l'après-midi fini dans la soirée
c'est non-stop pour le prix d'un billet
très raisonnable ça vaut vraiment le
coup de venir
merci beaucoup à nos courtiers et je le
rappelle les championnats d'europe c'est
du 19 au 23 octobre au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
merci michael et merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez vous pour un nouveau
numéro numéro mercredi 18h45 pour la
première diffusion ce sera notamment
avec jacques fournier pour la nouvelle
la saison d'itinéraires poétique sur
saint quentin en yvelines